You changed your mind on an
issue.
Today you called on the
Pennsylvania general assembly to
abolish the death penalty in
Pennsylvania.
Pennsylvania's last execution
was carried out in 1999.
In 2015 your predecessor,
governor Tom Wolfe, announced a
moratorium on executions.
Here's a clip of you announcing
this decision to change your
mind on this issue this morning.
>> Two critical truths became
clear to me about capital
sentencing in our commonwealth.
The system is fallible, and the
outcome is irreversible.
I will not sign any execution
warrants during my time as
governor of the commonwealth --
[ applause ]
>> So you were elected as
something of a law and order
kind of Democrat.
You got the endorsement of a lot
of police unions and such.
A, are you worried about this
decision undermining that at
all?
And B, why did you change your
mind?
>> You know, Jake, this isn't
about politics or any particular
constituency group.
This was a matter of conscience.
Candidly, Jake, something I
struggled with for quite some
time.
You know, when I ran for
attorney general back in 2016, I
was very outspoken that I
thought the capital punishment
system was just.
I thought it should be reserved
be for the most heinous of
crimes.
But I thought it was a just
punishment.
As time went on as attorney
general and cases came across my
desk, I found myself unable to
ever seek the death penalty.
In a private conversation I had
with my then 8, 9-year-old son
he asked me, you know, dad, how
is it that killing someone as a
punishment for them killing
someone else, how is it that
that's okay?
And you know, Jake, I couldn't
look my kid in the eye and
answer that question.
And then in 2018 when a murderer
went into the synagogue known as
tree of life --
>> Let me interrupt you right
there because I want to show the
clip that I think you're about
to referring to because in 2018
right after that horrific tree
of life synagogue shooting, the
deadliest act of anti-semitism
in the United States history, 11
people killed, six wounded, you
were attorney general and you
came on the show and you told me
that you wanted the death
penalty for the shooter.
And I confess, I've known you
for a long time.
I confess, I was surprised by
your position.
Let he me just roll that little
clip.
>> Yeah.
>> The shooter's already facing
29 federal charges, some of
which could theoretically be
punishable by death.
Do you want the feds to seek the
death penalty?
>> I do.
I think that this is an
appropriate case for the feds to
do that.
>> So go ahead.
I'm sorry to interrupt.
>> Yeah, no, I'm glad you played
that clip.
I referenced that in my remarks
today at the church in west
philly where I made this
announcement.
It was after that and a
combination of those cases
coming across my desk as A.G.,
my inability to look my own son
in the eye and explain my
position to him, and then I
witnessed the courage and the
grace of the families in
Pittsburgh, who had a loved one
killed while they worshiped, who
said to me, please, please
discourage them from pursuing
the death penalty.
If they could take that position
after suffering what they did,
then I certainly needed to
rethink my position.
And I did.
I spent a lot of time
rethinking.
I know a lot of times in
politics we get criticized for
thinking -- rethinking
positions, maybe changing our
views.
But I must say, it ultimately
came down to what I said in that
clip you showed before.
Our system is fallible, and the
outcome is irreversible.
And I just fundamentally could
not justify as governor of the
commonwealth of Pennsylvania
that we'd be in the business of
putting people to death.
It really was a journey for me,
in many ways a spiritual
journey, one inspired by the
good people in Pittsburgh, by
folks I've met along the way, by
my own son challenging he me on
a position that I honestly held
for many years and realizing
that it was not really a just
position.
I must say, Jake, I didn't stand
up in that church today and call
on the legislature to fix our
capital punishment system.
I think it is not fixable.
Instead I asked them
respectfully to come to the
table, Republican and Democrat
and join me in passing a law in
Pennsylvania to abolish the
death penalty.
And that is where I stand and
that is what I believe in, and
that to me is a matter of
conscience and morality.
>> It's two different things,
though, right?
One is the idea, the fallibility
of the system, which you don't
have to convince me of, that --
I mean, I just don't believe
that we've never as a country
put an innocent person to death.
I just don't believe it.
Just knowing how often innocent
people go to prison and are
later freed because of the
innocence project and on and on.
But you're also saying like even
if there was a way to guarantee
that every single person who
faced capital punishment was in
fact guilty undeniably, which is
of course impossible, but you're
also saying you still don't
believe in it.
>> That's exactly right.
I think to me it comes down to
an issue of morality and the
fundamental belief that our
commonwealth should not be in
the business of putting people
to death.
And listen, Jake, I'm someone as
attorney general who has put
people behind bars for the rest
of their lives.
I believe in stiff sentences.
I believe in making sure that
victims' interests are heard in
a courtroom and at sentencing.
I believe in making sure we take
dangerous people off the
streets.
I'll take a back seat to no one
on that.
I just don't believe that the
commonwealth should be putting
people to death.
>> One last question.
You and I went to the same high
school, a conservative jewish
day school -- I'm older than
you, so we're not classmates.
But the death penalty's fine
according to the old testament.
There's no problem with the
death penalty in judaism.
You talk about your faith a lot.
You talk about being an
observant Jew a lot.
What you're doing right now, I
wouldn't call it contrary to
scripture but it's not exactly
what we're taught in the bible.
>> Yeah.
It's interesting you raise that.
In many cases I reflect on my
faith.
Not so much on individual cases,
but really on something that
drives me into service.
And in fact, I reflected on my
jewish faith when I was at a
jesuit law school at Georgetown
law school and wrote a paper
about the death penalty and
actually drew on jewish law to
talk about how there were
instances where capital
punishment could be carried out.
It required a certain number of
direct eyewitnesses and a very
high evidentiary standard but it
was still allowed.
I thought about that when I
contemplated my position on this
as I entered public service, and
I guess perhaps it did drive my
position early on.
But as I evolved on this, as I
thought about it more, as I
reflected on my own conscience,
maybe not the literal writings
in our faith, I just found
myself in this position that I
announced today where I could
not in good conscience as the
governor of the commonwealth
ever sign an execution warrant
and instead I'll be signing
reprieves.
>> And you also know that
eyewitness testimony is pretty
much garbage quite often, as you
have risen through the ladder
from law school.
Not always but often.